[Music]
kim kardashian and northwest are back on
tick tock and giving a special shout out
to travis barker and machine gun kelly
it's always amazing on wednesday the 41
year old kkw beauty founder went full on
emo for a new video with her
eight-year-old daughter north and her
nine-year-old niece penelope disick
[Music]
that's kim northy and p rocking some
dark eye makeup and lipstick mouthing
the lyrics to emo girl by machine gun
kelly and willow smith featuring travis
barker
[Music]
of course what makes this video extra
cute is that travis is engaged to
penelope's mom kourtney kardashian
i love you
[Music]
naturally the clip has already racked up
millions of views which isn't really a
surprise since kim and north's joint
tick tock account is a hit
it's always so much fun the
mother-daughter duo has shared tons of
posts together since launching their
account in november
why not but turns out they've actually
been making tick tocks in secret since
2020. north has a
private tick-tock account so we we do
lots of tick tocks together she puts
them in drafts
she's not allowed to post them but we
have lots of tick tocks i might post one
soon and ever since kim and north went
public on the platform they've brought
all the quality content it's really lit
and fun and crazy holy spirit activate
activate activate i don't know how
you're going to top that kim even dances
guys
[Music]
even though she famously claims she
doesn't dance i'm like a notorious
non-dancer like it's a thing of course
this latest video marks the first time
kim and north have posted on tick tock
in over a month
[Music]
it's also their first post since north's
dad kanye west called out the skim's
founder in a since-deleted post to
instagram for letting their daughter be
on the app against his will
don't have my daughter
wearing lipstick on tick-tock i don't
have on tick-tock at all
if i'm gonna approve that at the time
kim responded to yay's claims with a
lengthy statement on her instagram story
defending north using the app with
parental supervision writing in part
divorce is difficult enough on our
children and kanye's obsession with
trying to control and manipulate our
situation so negatively and publicly is
only causing further pain for all and
when it comes to social media kim has
learned a thing or two about setting
boundaries i'm never not proud of
anything that i
have shared i have like no regrets just
don't be impulsive think it through
think about if you want people to know
this information because it'll always be
there and that will never change but you
need boundaries i think everyone does
[Music]
you